im hause sondern alle
ministerpräsidenten beschäftigt der
staatskanzlei waren dabei aber zum teil
in getrennten räumen damit wir die
abstandsregelung einhalten konnten wir
haben uns dann auch naturgemäß noch
einmal sehr intensiv mit der roma
pandemie beschäftigt sowohl was die
frage der wirtschaftlichen betätigung
anbelangt aber vielleicht zuerst dazu
fasst die frage der infektionen
anbelangt und haben dann auf der basis
eines im wesentlichen auch von den
ländern erarbeiteten in der vorkonferenz
beschlusses vereinbarung getroffen die
anschließend an das was wir auch beim
letzten mal beschlossen haben also es
bleibt dabei dass bürgerinnen und bürger
weiter grundsätzlich ein mindestabstand
von 1,5 meter einzuhalten haben und dass
diese maßnahme ergänzt wird durch eine
mund nasen bedeckung in bestimmten
öffentlichen bereichen verstärkte
hygienemaßnahmen und das instrument der
kontakt beschränkungen und das ist
sozusagen der kern wir haben das auch
vorher schon in den vergangenen
konferenzen oft gesagt solange es kein
medikament gibt solange es keinen
impfstoff gibt müssen wir mit der
pandemie leben und das sind die
basismaßnahmen sozusagen wie wir uns
gegenseitig schützen
und wenn wir anschauen wie die wie das
infektionsgeschehen ist was er im großen
ganzen jetzt doch auf einer beständigen
ebene einer kleineren infektionsfall pro
tag ist dann sehen wir dass gerade da wo
die abstandsregelungen ebenen
systematisch nicht eingehalten werden
können genau auch diese
ausbruchsgeschehen sind möglicherweise
im augenblick lokal und auch gut
nachvollziehbar und nach verfügbar für
die jeweiligen öffentlichen
gesundheitsämtern wenig für ihre arbeit
wirklich danken möchte
denn da wo ein ausbruchsgeschehen ist da
gibt es dann ja oft auch von einem tag
auf den anderen sehr viel zu tun
es wird noch einmal darauf verwiesen
dass dort wo die regionalliga
im infektionsgeschehen also mehr als 50
jahre infektion 300.000 einwohner in
sieben tagen die es erforderlich macht
weitergehende kontakt kontakt
beschränkungen erlassen werden können
und damit wir ein überregionales
infektionsgeschehen auch ändern können
die länder haben begrüßt das testen
jetzt nach der neuen verordnung des
bundesgesundheitsministers invite
breiterem maße möglich sind als das
bisher der fall war und haben auch die
korona bahn app noch einmal als einen
meilenstein in der korona bekämpfung
qualifiziert das haben wir gemeinsam
gemacht ich glaube das ist auch richtig
es ist eine maßnahme aber eine die
wirklich auch wirkung entfalten kann und
ich will allen die sie gestern schon
heruntergeladen haben ganz deutlich
danken dafür dass das doch ein ganz
guter staub war der natürlich noch
verstetigt werden muss wir haben dann
uns mit den wirtschaftlichen folgen
beschäftigt und ich freue mich dass es
gelungen ist mit den ländern gemeinsam
die maßnahmen die wir im konjunkturpaket
verabredet haben die auch die länder
betreffen und befassen
dass die sozusagen heute hier gebilligt
werden dass wir damit auch den kommenden
bundesratssitzungen optimistisch
entgegensehen können und das von der
bundesregierung aufgelegte
konjunkturpaket hat auch für einen
weiteren tagesordnungspunkt heute eine
sehr fruchtbringend impuls gegeben
nämlich die umsetzung der energiewende
im augenblick vielleicht nicht im fokus
des geschehens und der öffentlichen
diskussion aber ein ganz ganz wichtiges
thema wie geht es weiter mit dem ausbau
der erneuerung erneuerbaren energien wie
geht es weiter mit dem netzausbau wie
entwickeln wir unsere energieversorgung
in richtung des jahres 2030 hier ist
eine sehr gute vorarbeit geleistet
worden
wir werden auf diesen punkt dann
herbst also bei der nächsten regulären
mpk wieder zurückkommen wir müssen aber
alles tun damit netzausbau voran geht
plus ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
dadurch dass wir jetzt eine wasserstoff
strategie haben eine stabilisierung der
eeg-umlage vereinbart haben auch noch
mal geld für den ausbau der
ladeinfrastruktur und mehr vieles mehr
waren diese energie beratung auch
sozusagen einfach ermöglicht aber ich
möchte mich bei allen die daran
mitgearbeitet haben sehr bedanken es
geht ging dann noch um die besteuerung
des flächendeckenden mobilfunk
netzausbaus und das mobilfunk voller
programm des bundes auch hier großes
einvernehmen und insofern können wir
sozusagen sagen dass wir heute glaube
ich unsere arbeit mit getan haben im
einvernehmen von bund und ländern
was ja sich in den vergangenen monaten
wenn ich an unsere letzte physische
zusammenkunft hier in diesem hause mich
erinnere dann doch im grossen ganzen
natürlich auch manchmal
unterschiedlichen interessen recht gut
geklappt hat und ich hoffe dass wir das
auch weiter in den nächsten monaten zu
machen
denn und das zeigt das
konjunkturprogramm ja auch noch mal und
auch der nachtragshaushalt den wir heute
beschlossen haben im bundeskabinett der
wirtschaftliche einschnitt ist der
gravierendste den wir in der geschichte
der bundesrepublik deutschland erlebt
haben und wir werden viel kraft brauchen
um sozusagen den weg auch weiter gut zu
gehen damit der wohlstand in unserem
lande sich vernünftig entwickeln kann
für die menschen und die bürgerinnen und
bürger ja das von meiner seite frau
bundeskanzler meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren es war der tatort eine sehr
gute sitzung die wir auch intensiv
gemeinschaftlich vorbereitet haben das
war unser klarer anspruch dass wir heute
zu gemeinschaftlichen ergebnissen kommen
und dass sie auch den bürgern der bürger
des landes in bezug auf corona auch ein
klares bild vermitteln dass grundregeln
für die weitere entwicklung bekämpfung
der pandemie für uns alle gelten und für
uns alle von wichtiger bedeutung sind
zwar nach jeweiligen infektionsgeschehen
an der einen stelle mal etwas anders
angewendet werden aber die grundregeln
die grundphilosophie zur bekämpfung von
corona
haben alle akzeptiert und alle
mitgetragen das ist ein wichtiges
gemeinschaftliches ergebnis warum
nach wie vor ist corona der korona hält
die welt in atem
wir leben in einigen teilen der welt
dramatische entwicklungen erleben
rückfälle in bestimmten ländern wie in
china
und wenn wir ehrlich sind sind länder
die eine andere strategie als
deutschland angewendet haben wie
beispielsweise schweden heute nicht nur
wirtschaftlich genauso betroffen wie wir
sondern leben in der die zahl der
todesfälle auf 100000 einwohner
umgerechnet eine dramatisch höhere zahl
als bei uns das was man immer wieder
sagen muss dass bund und länder die
letzten monate gemacht haben hat
tausende wahrscheinlich zehntausende
leben gerettet
und bei aller kritik und
herausforderungen sorgen der zukunft
dafür nicht vergessen dass dieses
gemeinschaftliche agieren der letzten
monate ein gesamt beweis war dass die
deutsch das deutsche volk die deutsche
gesellschaft die bevölkerung gut
mitgemacht hat mit viel geduld dass wir
aber auch die richtigen
weichenstellungen getroffen haben das
ist mir ganz wichtig dass wir das sagen
können aber wir sind deswegen in der
lage erleichterungen zu machen wenn ich
an meinem bundesland denke wir waren ja
am stärksten betroffen
wir haben nach dem heutigen tag nur noch
0,06 prozent der bayerischen bevölkerung
erkrankt und infiziert haben die zahl um
95 prozent von rückstand auf heute
reduziert als es hat wirklich gut
funktioniert es gibt aber keinen anlass
jetzt leichtfertig zu treffen das was
uns eint ist natürlich ist erleichterung
mehr normalität mehr lebensfreude
wichtig aber nicht ohne vernunft
diese vernunft ist ganz entscheidend
auch in der zukunft wir dürfen die
erfolge nicht leichtfertig verspielen
wir dürfen keine hoppla hopp
entscheidungen treffen sondern müssen
mit umsicht und vorsicht schritt für
schritt weiter gehen und das hat das
wird glaube ich auch geeint in den
gemeinsamen bemühen in den beschlüssen
des darzustellen also erleichterung ja
aber mit umsicht und köpfchen
was sind die punkte die bundeskanzlerin
hat es ja schon benannt ich will es noch
ergänzen
abstand halten hygiene masten ist ganz
entscheidend und kontakt beschränkungen
ja die einen wenn es stärker noch machen
beispielsweise wir aber es sind alle
einig dass zum beispiel in alten und
pflegeheimen dass dort etwas ganz
wichtig ist auch kontakte zu
kontrollieren und zu beschränken weil
dort eine ganz große gefahr besteht für
leib und leben von roland gruppen
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir diese
grundregeln einhalten
die sind nicht außer kraft wir müssen
weiter geltend für die nächsten monate
wir brauchen ein stärkeres testsystem
auch das ist heute ganz klar wir in
bayern entwickeln gerade eine 24 stunden
garantie für symptomatische fälle und
wohl noch ganz bewusst wir haben uns ja
noch mal vereinbart dass wir nach den
schulferien für alle versuchen den
regelbetrieb in den schulen und kitas
generell zu machen
das wird aber nur gehen auch mit der
entsprechenden akzeptanz von bevölkerung
und auch beispielsweise der pädagogen
wir uns ganz wichtig sind dass wir das
gemeinschaftlich machen auch dann nicht
zu überstürzen sondern mit den lehrern
lehrerin unserem land das ganze planen
dass da auch angebote sein müssen für
sehr breite testmöglichkeiten in schulen
oder kitas und wenn das dann stattfindet
haben uns darauf geeinigt sind auch
dankbar den bund besteht hier die
einstimmige meinung das ist dann auch
von der bezahlung über den kassen
gemacht wird dann noch mal herzlichen
dank und das gesundheitssystem muss
weiter ausgebaut werden
kein rückfall in die zeit vor corona
nach dem motto das hat sich erledigt
sondern sukzessive weiter arbeiten und
vorbereiten für die zukunft es ist wie
bei der feuerwehr die feuerwehr schafft
man nicht ab nur weil es weniger weil es
nicht mehr brennt oder weil es nicht
mehr so stark brennt corona ist wie ein
funke der mitten ein neues buch feuer
auslösen kann
und da sieht es an einzelfällen gestern
die der in nordrhein-westfalen anderswo
ein bestimmter hof eine
gemeinschaftsunterkunft sofort hat man
eine fülle von solchen entwicklungen
dann stellt er fest dass die einer
familienfeier in deutschland auch schon
wieder erste ausgangspunkt ist zumindest
das ganze sehr sehr ernst zu ehren
zweiter punkt oder zu ergänzen wenn wir
uns bei den großveranstaltungen auch
noch mal klar kommuniziert dass das bis
oktober
insbesondere dann wenn überhaupt keine
chance der nachverfolgbarkeit besteht
dass der unterschied zur familienfeier
da kann man in der regel sagen wir ist
da
also deinen wenigsten geburtstagsfeiern
kommt irgendjemand sondern man kann das
nachvollziehen es ist bei
großveranstaltungen nicht der fall
man wird es dann im herbst bewerten und
auch natürlich vor der karnevalssaison
noch einmal darüber nachdenken ob das
überhaupt wieder geeignet ist oder nicht
persönlich sagen ich bin da sehr
vorsichtig und zurückhaltend man wird
sehen
zweiter punkt bundeskanzlern
angesprochen wir haben ja das
konjunkturpaket ausdrücklich begrüßt
selbst war mit dabei als wir es
erarbeitet haben ich glaube es ist und
bleibt ein ganz großer wurf den jetzt
schleunigst umsetzen müssen und nicht
zerreden
deswegen die länder sich auch klar
obwohl es gar nicht mal ein paket drin
stand in der vereinbarung bereit erklärt
über die kofinanzierung zu machen
gewerbesteuer nv beim bereich der kita
entwicklung die das wir begrüßen
mitnehmen wollen und das auch
entsprechend unterstützen auch beim
digital packt danke einen bund dass er
da auch bereit ist nicht nur die
umsetzung sondern auch da sich an
betriebskosten zu beteiligen das ist
übrigens etwas was neues in der
deutschen struktur normaler das waren
für betriebskosten immer die länder
zuständig aber auch bei kita- oder
beispielsweise bei digital bot ab und
steigt ein oder redet darüber dass zu
tun das ist schon auch für die kommunen
und viele länder ein ganz wichtiges ein
ganz wichtiges signal
deswegen zusammenfassend gesagt das war
übrigens auch von der stimmung deutlich
auf der einen seite konzentrierter aber
auch harmonisch ist uns glaube ich ein
stück gut getan wie damals die
jeweiligen image und gestik noch besser
zu ahnen und um zu erfassen dass sie war
das wird glaube ich eine eine gute
konferenz mit dem sehr guten auch
gemeinschaftlichen ergebnis und auch
einer wieder noch verbesserten
vertrauensbasis wenn ich das so sagen
darf wir haben den letzten monaten ja
mal die anderen der sitzung habe es hoch
herging und eine halbe stunde später
vieles wieder neu interpretiert wurde
von dem was schriftlich fixiert wurde
eine bessere hoffnung aber letzter satz
wir müssen einfach den weg den wir
gefunden haben als unser land mit
seriosität und souveränität einfach
stück für stück weiter gehen gibt kein
anlass zur umkehr zur abkehr sondern dem
weg stück für stück mit vernunft und
auch ein stück optimismus aber vor allem
mit vernunft weitergehen
ja auch nach meiner einschätzung war es
heute sehr viel einfacher dass wir uns
auf die gemeinsamen fragen zum
infektionsschutz noch einmal
verständigen wir haben heute ja
fortgesetzt einige regelungen die uns in
den letzten monaten sehr geholfen haben
die infektions dynamik zu verlangsamen
und das war sehr spürbar obwohl es
wirklich sehr wenige neuinfektionen nur
noch gibt in deutschland in einigen
ländern sind es nur noch vereinzelte
infektionen war der gemeinsame geist
das darf uns nicht zu dem irrtum führen
dass wir die dinge weniger ernst nehmen
und deswegen haben wir sowohl bei
großveranstaltungen wie auch bei vielen
anderen fragen sei einvernehmlich gesagt
wir bleiben auf einem sehr vorsichtigen
kurs dennoch haben wir keine impfung
noch haben wir kein medikament kann die
natürliche immunität wir müssen weiter
sehr sehr vorsichtig durch diese
pandemie steuern bei dem zweiten thema
wie wir die wirtschaftlichen folgen in
den griff bekommen wie wir uns um die
langfrist wirkungen gedanken machen da
hatten wir ein sehr gutes bundes
konjunkturprogramm an dass wir jetzt
unsere beratung anknüpfen können
wir haben das sehr begrüßt was der bund
auf den weg gebracht hat die länder
werden ihren beitrag dazu legen viele
landesprogramme greifen ja in die
systematik die der bund hat auch
sinnvoll ein das heißt wir haben nicht
nur konjunkturimpulse generell sondern
wir setzen die impulse so dass die
wichtigen zukunftsthemen wie vor corinna
wichtig waren die jetzt noch dringlicher
sind gleich mit vorangebracht werden
und das sind eben die themen der der e
mobilität der wasserstofftechnologie
viele fragen die wir ohnehin
voranbringen wollten vor der krone krise
und das ist eben dann heute ich wie
heute die ich finde sehr gut gelungen
wir haben ja ein
beschluss gefasst zur energiewende
eigentlich ein thema was wir uns im märz
vor der krise sowieso als sonderthema
vorgenommen haben das jetzt drei monate
später auf sehr gute art und weise
zusammengefasst worden ist viele punkte
die im märz noch gar nicht so ganz klar
waren sind jetzt einvernehmlich
vereinbart wir haben jetzt tatsächlich
viele entscheidende punkte beschlossen
es soll eben eine erhöhung der offshore
windenergie geben der photovoltaik
photovoltaik decke fällt jetzt weg
wir werden gemeinsam auch onshore die
windenergie voranbringen länder sind
überzeugt dass sie die flächen zur
verfügung stellen müssen
die haben eine sinnvolle
abstandsregelung eine opt in regelung
vereinbart also wer möchte kann die
einheitliche regelung in anspruch nehmen
aber zunächst einmal sind die länder
frei die abstandsregelung so zu treffen
wie sie nötig ist damit die windenergie
onshore voran geht und wir haben ganz
wesentliche beschlüsse gefasst wie mit
der eeg umlage in zukunft umzugehen ist
es gibt diese begrenzung der eeg-umlage
2020 21 22 und es wird sinnvolle
regelungen geben damit die eeg umlage
nicht zu einem menschen wird sondern
dass sie passt zu dem was wir in der
grünen wasserstoff produktion brauchen
was wir in der integration von moderner
erneuerbarer energie in die
energielandschaft benötigen denn auch
das ist ja stand teil der erkenntnis wir
werden in den nächsten zehn jahren nicht
nur die bisherigen strombedarf zu 65
prozent durch erneuerbare energien
formen abdecken müssen sondern wir
werden insgesamt einen sehr viel höheren
stromverbrauch haben und darauf müssen
alle planungen auch das monitoring
ausgerichtet sein
das ist etwas was in diesem beschluss
enthalten ist und insofern eine echte
zukunftsperspektive eine positive
perspektive auf energiewende und
klimaschutz in deutschland die sich aus
der korona panini heraus mit großer
kraft
und eben auch mit mit viel
finanzierungsaufwand jetzt ergibt dann
kommen wir zu ihren fragen bietet nur
eine pro journalist ist beginnt app lang
von pia frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben
die app erwähnt die korona app können
sie uns sagen haben sie die app selber
runtergeladen und wie bestimmt sie jetzt
ihren alltag haben sie da heute schon
häufiger mal drauf geguckt und
also herr söder möchte sich da auch zu
äußern gerne das war die eine frage
meinen kommunikationsverhalten ja
sowieso keine auskunft geben
sage ich auch nicht viel dazu außer das
was ich schon mal gesagt habe dass ich
willens bin diese app zu nutzen
werden solche sitzungen ergibt sich hin
und wieder die gelegenheit die gedanken
obwohl er davor sitzen ist und
eigentlich ganz auge und ohr sein sollte
man weiß ja man muss gesagt wird frau
bundeskanzlerin dieses physische treffen
heute zeigt ja auch dass deutschland das
auch die bundesstaaten eine art
normalität im umgang mit corona jetzt
einmal gefunden haben dann sind wir kurz
davor erhebliche reisebewegungen in
deutschland zu haben und auch ins
ausland
inwieweit bereiten sie sich auf eine
mögliche zweite welle vor und was würden
sie jetzt schon anders machen
vor allen dingen im hinblick nicht nur
auf fallzahlen sondern auch im hinblick
darauf was für schäden dadurch corona
maßnahmen auch entstanden sind gerade im
hinblick auf schulen beschulung solche
fragen also wir beobachten ja das
infektionsgeschehen egal ob in den
ländern oder im bund sehr sehr
aufmerksam und die ganze aufmerksamkeit
richtet sich darauf ist es möglich das
infektionsgeschehen unter kontrolle zu
halten und regional zu lassen und
deshalb begrüße ich auch sehr dass wenn
sie heute im landkreis gütersloh zum
beispiel
dann solches gehäuftes
infektionsgeschehen auftritt dass dann
dort auch sofort maßnahmen ergriffen
werden zum beispiel die schulen
geschlossen werden und ähnliches dass es
genau in dem sinn den wir uns ja auch
überlegt haben damit dann nicht sich
dinge verbreiten die wir nicht
verbreiten wollten wir bereiten uns
darauf vor dass wir immer reagieren
können es geht ja darum zu verhindern
dass wir wieder ein unkontrolliertes
infektionsgeschehen haben und das
spiegelt sich wider in denen hier heute
getroffenen maßnahmen dass wir den
menschen sagen ihr müsst weiter
ausdehnen abstand achten
dieser abstand ist einzuhalten ich
glaube das kann man gar nicht oft genug
sagen wenn man das allgemeine auch
verhalten an manchen stellen sieht das
ist sehr sehr ernst gemeint dort wohnt
dieser abstand nicht einzuhalten ist ist
mussten und nasenschutz von
notwendigkeit und gleichzeitig ist eben
auch das weiter notwendig zum beispiel
auch solche großveranstaltungen wo diese
abstandsregeln für viele viele menschen
nicht eingehalten werden können eben
weiter nicht zuzulassen
wir müssen jetzt sehen natürlich ist
durch die kreuz und quer bewegung durch
das land aber auch im europäischen
ausland
die frage der verbreitung von
infektionen noch mal in einer anderen
art und weise auf der tagesordnung
deshalb haben wir auch sehr darauf
geachtet dass wir den öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst und sozusagen stärken
und die länder haben das ja zum teil
auch schon getan und es wird auch sehr
wichtig sein dass die gesundheitsämter
miteinander kommunizieren können auch
daran müssen wir noch weiter arbeiten
denn wenn jemand an der ostsee war aber
aus bayern oder
hamburg gekommen ist dann ist natürlich
wichtig dass die gesundheitsämter auch
miteinander im engen kontakt sind als
solche fragen beschäftigen uns und
deshalb arbeiten wir darauf hin dass es
eben genau nicht zu dem kommt was sie
gesagt haben sondern dass wir das so
unter kontrolle halten wir es im
augenblick haben ja eine frage an sie
beide ministerpräsident war jetzt nicht
ganz klar was sie gesagt haben zu den zu
den großveranstaltungen sie sagten
design oder würden verboten sein
wenn wenn sich da der eine infektion
nicht rückverfolgen ließe heißt das da
ist schon die bei der verlängerung
dieses verbots eine gewisse aufweichung
gemacht worden oder ist das praktisch
genau dieselbe sprache noch mal
verlängert ist das ist ausgeweitet
worden für den fall dass eine dass weder
hygienemaßnahmen noch eine
nachvollziehbarkeit geht das ist die
ergänzung der mann hatte das heißt da
wird schon da gibt es denkbare
möglichkeiten bei großveranstaltungen
nicht in dem sinn immer die klassische
hatten also die klassischen
starkbierfest oder riesigen
veranstaltung wie oktoberfest sondern
sind alles sehr kleine aber da ist
irgendwie flexibilität das war der
kompromiss quasi jemand treffen müsste
es wird natürlich von dem einen land
etwas strenger interpretiert voneinander
bisschen anders es wird sich aber auch
zeigen ehrlich gesagt wie die
entwicklung bis nach den ferien ist
schließt dann was die bundeskanzlerin
sagt nicht gibt zu ich bin da schon
etwas in sorge videos wird das wird
jetzt am anfang glaube ich ihm bei den
auslandsreisen gut beachtet werden aber
wenn zwei drei wochen sonne sommer und
alles möglich stattfindet hoffe sehr
dass der ballermann kein zweites ist
gebert wir sind ein bisschen auch an der
stelle besonders sensibel war der von
bayern eben über österreich in der
faschingswoche eine sehr starke
infektion entwicklung hatten deswegen
wird nach den ferien dann mal sehen und
neu beraten ist geht aber zb sind sich
die meisten einig dass auch
karnevalsveranstaltung länder eher
schwerer vorstellbar sind aber im winter
ist noch schritt für schritt
leben für fried süddeutsche
ich hätte jetzt nächsten jahr eine
klarstellung frage frau bundeskanzlerin
sie sagten einmal anfange in
verschiedenen räumen heißt es dass nicht
alle ministerpräsidenten mit ihnen in
einem raum waren doch aber die chefs der
staatskanzleien waren nicht alle im
selben raum also die ministerpräsidenten
waren alle im gleichen raum hatten zum
teil mit 3 2 und 3 vorlieb zu nehmen was
sicherlich auch ungewohnt war aber hatte
keine tiefere bedeutung sehr wohl saas
sowie im kabinett wie im kabinett
wenn meine eigentliche frage wäre hat
die die ganztagsbetreuung eine rolle
gespielt der streit zwischen bund und
ländern um die finanzierung und vorstoß
von frau gegen frau carlitscheck dass
das jetzt beschleunigt werden so ja das
habt eine rolle gespielt und wir sind
auch zu einem konstruktiven ergebnis
gekommen und haben sozusagen nicht nur
das wiederholt was wir im
konjunkturpaket vereinbart hatten
sondern sind auch noch mal
zurückgekommen auf den rahmen in dem das
alles abläuft und das geht ja zurück auf
die koalitionsvereinbarung die wir
beschlossen haben dass wir einen
rechtsanspruch auf ganztagsbetreuung
wollen und das ist sehr ausführlich
diskutiert worden dass darüber ein
vertiefte gespräch führen geführt werden
muss wie man das genau umsetzen kann
denn da hängen sehr viele fragen dran
schon wenn man die
koalitionsvereinbarung sieht dann weiß
man welche modalitäten da zu beachten
sind wie mit den kommunalen
spitzenverbänden gesprochen werden soll
und wie die finanzierung ist bei der
finanzierung sind es eben nicht nur
bauliche maßnahmen sondern das sind auch
maßnahmen der des betriebs natürlich und
über diesen punkt ist noch mal sehr
vertieft gesprochen worden wir haben ja
auch bei der kita-betreuung markus söder
hat es gesagt uns auch an den
betriebskosten beteiligt und eine
ähnliche diskus
dann werden wir jetzt zeitnah auch im
zusammenhang mit den fragen der das
rechtsanspruch auf ganztagsbetreuung
führen das ist ein besitzer
die diskussion war wie ich fand wichtig
aber sie hat auch gezeigt dass natürlich
gerade in den jetzigen zeiten es nicht
so ganz einfach ist
die finanziellen voraussetzungen auf
allen seiten zu schaffen
trotzdem ist das generöse angebot des
bundes gut aufgenommen worden
entschuldigung grund wurden wir gehen
das ist natürlich intensiv geredet
worden darum weil insbesondere in
flächenländern das mit extrem hohen
kosten verbunden ist muss man einfach
nicht einsehen und die bisherigen
finanzangebote die sehr großzügig sind
von seiten des bundes also wie lange
sich die herausforderung finanziell
nicht an deren abdecken können dass
irgendwas war wichtig ist dass wir
einerseits natürlich gemeinschaftlich
das interesse haben die
betreuungssituation immer weiter zu
verbessern das ist das klare anlegen von
allen der weg wie es dorthin geht da
gibt es noch eine reihe von gesprächen
haben wir eigentlich auf der minister
wissen eben das erste mal so ausführlich
darüber geredet dass der fachminister
ebene schon ausführlicher wenn wir uns
vereinbart dass jetzt dann auf der
nächsten mpk ausführlicher zu machen um
auch mal die ganzen problemen und punkte
zu diskutieren was die fachlichkeit
betrifft und was jetzt heute glaube ich
der fortschritt ist und aus unserer
sicht ein fortschritt ist dass wir
festgehalten
das ist auch ein betriebskosten geht
also nicht nur baumaßnahmen
denn viele länder ist das bauen nicht es
kein problem das ist ein problem aber
nicht allein so dass viren dauerhaften
weg überlegen müssen was das thema
betriebskosten finanzierung und dann
letztlich auch personalfragen wirklich
denn das ist die jetzt ganz große
herausforderung da sind wir dankbar über
das entgegenkommen des bundes dass wir
darüber reden werden
ohne jetzt ein abschließendes ergebnis
damit zu haben und haben zu können
vorlegen vorlesen damit gehen sie ja
nachher aussehen wenn bund und länder
werden zügig daran arbeiten die
voraussetzungen für ein
anspruch auf ganztagsbetreuung
einschließlich seiner finanzierung
anschließend einschließlich der
betriebskosten einvernehmlich zu klären
und auf dieser grundlage einen solchen
zu schaffen dann werden wir doppelt so
genau auf die 150 jahren frau vaters ja
ich wollte gerne noch mal zurück zu
corona und wüsste gerne wie sie
eigentlich den beginn einer zweiten
welle definieren das heißt ab welchem
punkt ist es nicht mehr ein lokales
regionales geschehen sondern ab welchem
punkt ist wieder was was alle betrifft
und was passiert dann eigentlich wie ist
der genaue sozusagen schlachtplan
notfallplan um dann dem ganzen herr zu
werden haben sie möglicherweise auch
überlegt dass der bund dann angesichts
des hin und her was teilweise gab es
zwischen den ländern mehr kompetenzen
kriegt im katastrophenschutz da man
damit haben wir uns heute nicht
beschäftigt und ich weiß es nicht ich
bin eigentlich ganz zufrieden dass wir
im augenblick eine konstante zahl von
infektionen haben und zwar nachdem
beobachten das sehr genau
wir sind von einem exponentiellen
wachstum weit entfernt wir sind mit dem
erfolg tor immer so um die 1 mal drüber
mal drunter
es wird sehr viel getestet
dass es gut und es kann sogar noch mehr
getestet werden wir haben sowohl die
kapazitäten und deshalb sitzen wir jetzt
unsere ganze kraft erst mal darauf die
lage so in bei zunehmenden lockerungen
und zunehmenden bewegungen auch so zu
verfolgen und wir sind jederzeit
handlungsfähig wenn sich das ändern
sollte aber ich weiß nicht warum ich
mich jetzt mit dingen
permanent beschäftigen sollte die gott
sei dank nicht auf der tagesordnung
stehen
ich glaube dass wir im augenblick sehr
gut arbeitende gesundheitsämter haben
die ziemlich robust auch zuschlagen sage
ich jetzt mal wenn etwas irgendwo
auftritt und das muss so bleiben und ich
bin auch sehr dankbar dass viel kraft
darauf verwendet wird dass das lokale
geschehen eingedämmt wird und das ist ja
wenn sie sich dann vorstellen dass sie
wie hunderte von familien in quarantäne
schicken müssen und von einem tag auf
den anderen dass es seine harte arbeit
aber die muss gemacht werden und wir
sehen ja an diesen ausbrüchen auch dass
es nicht weg ist das virus das ist
darauf konzentrieren wird gewalt dass
diese zweite welle plötzlich konnte dann
stehen wir da sondern wir sind noch
aufmerksamer als [ __ ] wir testen
vielmehr die tests strategie die jetzt
entwickelt worden ist ist ja gerade
dafür gedacht dass wir so bald wir jetzt
wieder neu auftreten an unerwarteter
stelle haben dass wir zum beispiel sehr
schnell dann in kitas und schulen in
anderen einrichtungen das umgebungs feld
testen und dann beides tun es früher zu
erkennen aber dadurch eben auch sehr
viel konsequenter einzelne solcher keine
herde geben die sich generalisieren so
dass wir also keine zweite welle erleben
im sinne von es kommt von außen etwas
auf uns zu und wir sind genauso wie in
der ersten welle davor sondern das was
wir jetzt besprochen haben dass wir
aufmerksam bleiben dass wir diese tests
strategie haben dass wir die er tragen
dass wir ein gesundheitsschädliches
gesundheitswesen haben wir schon jetzt
sehr viel besser ausgestattet ist und
das wollen wir dass man eine idee
gegeben noch einmal gesprochen wird
welche technischen und personellen
unterstützung es zusätzlich geben kann
damit das öffentliche gesundheitswesen
noch aufmerksamer und auch wirksamer ist
in der begrenzung von infektionsherden
und vor diesem hintergrund sind wir sehr
beruhigt dass das jetzt wirklich auch
konsens ist auf in allen ländern und
beim bund dass wir diese zweite welle
dadurch eben vermeiden
also wir passen auch bei den
reisehinweisen sehr stark wir haben für
schweden eben zum beispiel wegen der
infektions lage dort das nicht
freigegeben wie wir es für alle anderen
europäischen ländern freigegeben haben
zweitens wir machen in der tat nochmals
verstärkung des öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienstes wollen wir im august
einen solchen gipfel machen wo wir mit
den gesundheitsämtern mit den landräten
mit den oberbürgermeistern darüber reden
also das wird ein virtueller gipfel
werden weil es sind ja auch sehr sehr
viele leute wir haben um die 400
gesundheitsämter in deutschland aber um
genau da auch den fokus darauf zu setzen
dass uns das nicht entgleitet das ist
termine gibt muss das leider die letzte
frage gewesen sein beton mehr
verständnis und danke